Welcome to the show, a very special Shenango
bar to everyone who is celebrating the new
year today,
but even that could not keep us away from
the show today and good thing because so much
happened over the weekend to start with. Donald
Trump has cracked over the weekend tweeting
about the same craziness about impeachment,
including a ridiculous Fox news segment nearly
20 times alone there close to a hundred tweets
in total. I don't even know the exact number
and starting to suggest that his own impeachment
could lead to an American civil war. We're
going to get to all of the elements of this
Donald Trump tweeting endlessly, a Fox news
segment that reeked of desperation. I am coining
the term Ajit trashed today because the term
Ajit prop is not quite accurate. It's a little
too Soviet in its connotations to describe
what it is that Fox news has been displaying
in defense of Donald Trump against impeachment.
So I'm calling what Fox is producing and Trump
is tweeting out better named Ajit trash.
Let's try to get that one into urban dictionary.
Trump also threatening civil war if he is
impeached, truly losing it. So let's look
at this extraordinarily childish, embarrassing,
diluted behavior of what is ultimately a panicked
and terrified man. That's what we have today
in Donald Trump. Look at this nonstop barrage
of failed attempts at using the English language
by Donald Trump, including nearly a dozen
tweets this morning. Three tweets this morning
about Adam Schiff that make no sense center,
just the normal types of attacks we would
see normally from internet trolls. But this
is the president of the United States earlier
with another three tweet storm about China
quoting, known Trump, sycophantic Brown noser,
Maria Bartiromo, who have spoken about before.
And of course raising the term witch hunt.
That puts us up to six tweets. Then he starts
tweeting. Anyone who will defend him, he will
just retweet them anywhere that'll get you
retweeted by Donald Trump.
One interview with Republican Kevin McCarthy
who defended Trump. Another of course with
the completely unhinged and outrageous Republican
Senator Lindsey Graham, who has become one
of Trump's, uh, prominent defenders, another
of Trump attorney, Rudy Giuliani, Donald Donald
Trump retweeting that. Another TV segment
from Lou Dobbs on Fox business. We're now
up to 10 tweets. This is just the last nine
hours and this is all nothing compared to
what else happened on Twitter with Trump.
Then we go to late last night and this is
when Trump really was getting himself wound
up. We're going sort of in reverse chronological
order in groups here now with these, I'm not
going to read every tweet because it's too
insane and it's just too much. Trump attacking
Nancy Pelosi talking about impeachment quoting,
Fox news and the radical left and talking
about Hillary Clinton and going after the
whistle blower. These are the endless unending
tweets of an unwell man and we are now up
to 21 tweets about this in the prior 12 hours,
21 tweets, and then Trump goes onto the Fox
news.
Ajit trash. There was a completely loony segment
and I encourage you to watch it. It's like
close to 10 minutes long and it featured this
whacked out right-winger and Mark Levin who
some, I think it was Sean Hannity, who started
calling him the great one and it's like a
completely meaningless nickname, and of course,
Mark Levin defended Trump and said, this is
all an unconstitutional attempt to remove
Donald Trump from power by a means other than
an election. Trump tweeted that segment endless
times hilariously sandwiched with a Rosh Hashanah
greeting in the middle, not counting that
we are up to 24 tweets in the last slightly
more than 12 hours related to Donald Trump's
impeachment. And then I'm not going to get
into this in detail. Re tweeting endless,
just random people who went on Twitter and
said, Mark Levin crushed it on Fox news. I'm
not going to read each one, but these are
just random Trump sycophants who agree with
a clueless Fox news.
Ajit trash clown about how great and innocent
Donald Trump is. About 30 tweets of that.
Just random people who Donald Trump has retweeted
more than a dozen others. We're talking about
between the tweets and the retweets and the
Ajit trash tweets. I think we're talking about
a hundred or so tweets here in total dating
back to the beginning of the weekend. Trump
just re tweeting anybody who's willing to
defend him on Fox news and a a re tweeting
Twitter randos who are saying good things
about him and then the cherry on top, the
specific threat of a civil war. Going back
to one of Donald Trump's tweets and retweets,
quoting pastor Robert Jeffress or GFRs, he's
a radical extremist himself who we've spoken
about before. Saying quote, if the Democrats
are successful in removing the president from
office, which they will never be, it will
cause a civil war like fracture in this nation
from which our country will never heal.
That's Donald Trump quoting pastor Robert
GFRs via Fox news on Twitter. This is not
the behavior of a well person. This is not
the behavior of an innocent person. This is
not the behavior of someone who has no interest
in interfering or tampering with witnesses
in what is now an increasingly popular impeachment
inquiry against Donald Trump, which I will
talk about next. The only real debate, I mean,
listen, when I look at this nearly a hundred
tweets over the weekend, president of the
United States, I don't debate. Wow. Does Donald
Trump act like an innocent or guilty person?
The ship has sailed on that debate. I don't
ask myself, is Trump coherently using the
English language to communicate things of
meaning or is he not? The guy is completely
incoherent. That's not a debate in my mind.
The only real question I have is, is the logical
next place for Trump to be removed from office
and put in prison or to be removed from office
and put in a mental institution, and I don't
mean that satirically.
I don't mean it to be in any way demeaning
or stigmatizing or making fun of actual mental
illness. And I know a lot of people get mad
and they say, David, you know you're, you're
sort of insulting mentally ill people when
you say Trump may be mentally ill. He's just
a terrible person. I don't know the answer.
This is not an [inaudible]. This is not a
well person. That's what I can tell you. The
other remaining questions are increasingly
being answered by these erratic and nonstop
tweets and the only question I have is where
is the logical next resting ground for Donald
Trump?